Shakespeare Britain of course very
famously that all the world's a stage
right and that's really the kind of
picture of metaphor that Newton has in
mind throughout his greatest work that
Principia the planets will move around
the Comets will orbit the Sun the apples
will fall all that happens all that
action takes place a cron a kind of
perfectly rigid unchanging stage that
stage then space and time for Newton
so Newton says very famously space and
time are each absolute they flow without
compromise there's nothing that happens
on that stage is going to affect the
stage itself they're not actors in the
drama newton's view of time is the what
I would call the everyday notion of time
that we that we grow up with that we
become familiar with in our everyday
lives the notion that time is universal
it's the same for everyone everywhere no
matter what they're doing that it ticks
away at a constant rate and time is
passing equally and exactly the same for
everyone no matter what they're doing
and all of our everyday experience
points to this being the correct notion
of time and we come to to Einstein and
especially with his general theory of
relativity his theory of gravity space
and time were their Union into space
time now has become an actor in the play
it's not sort of set off apart from the
other things like the planets whizzing
around or comets or apples it's not part
of that story so that the other actors
say large masses like the Sun can
actually have an impact that can affect
the shape of space the flow of time in
its vicinity and vice versa so they
become part of the kind of stage play
not set off so Newton had said time and
space were first of all separate from
each other and we're sort of absolute
apart distinct and I sign starts folding
them in to the kind of larger drama in
Einstein's theory of gravity time
becomes personal so the time that
elapses for me is entirely personal to
me the time
lapsus for anyone is entirely personal
to them and the way that time elapses
the way that time flows for an
individual is completely dependent on
where they are and what they're doing so
if all the world's a stage then the
structure of that stage is the structure
of space-time this entity that that
Einstein introduced